hi I'm Jessica Clemons of new rockstars
and I'm going to give you as many Easter
eggs as I can in under a minute and
movie fun facts let's just get into it
not only did Jen Ortega learn to play
the cello she took fencing archery
canoeing German and boxing lessons to
prep for a Rolex Wednesday and top gun
Maverick the only pilot to crash during
training was Phoenix named after the
mythical bird who rises from its ashes
she then proceeds to fly in the final
mission the book that Channing Tatum's
reading and bullet train is one of
Sandra Bullock's character's book in the
lost city which is starring Channing
Tatum with a cameo made by Brad Pitt and
one point in the movie Coraline shows 16
different expressions in the span of 35
seconds Ace Ventura Pet Detective the
mask and Dumb and Dumber all came out in
1994 all-starring Jim Carrey the tree
under which the Corpse Bride was buried
is the same one from Sleepy Hollow where
the Headless Horseman was buried and a
flashback scene where Sam is selling his
various onion products a man walks up to
Sam and gives them a bottle of onion
juice this is the author Louis sacker of
holes when Rapunzel is singing the song
I've Got a dream in the bar you can see
Pinocchio at the top of the screen